Afterwards, go ahead and start BlueJ, and follow along what I'm doing here.
Select the Project Option, open a project, navigate to the folder into which
you have unzipped the starter code, go to lesson one and then to hello, and
here you get an icon that represents out first program. Double-click on it, and
a window pops up with the program code. Here again is the line that I said is
the most important one. We'll have a closer look at the bits and pieces of the
statement later, but right now let me show you how to execute a program. Click
on the button that says Compile. Now your program is translated from the Java
language into a lower-level language that the computer can execute efficiently.
We don't normally have to worry about that process, except we have to remember
to hit the Compile button before running the program. Now back in the main
display, right-click on this box. Select the second line that contains the word
main, and that launches the main part of our program. You get a dialogue here
where you should simply click OK. As soon as you do that, another window pops
up and [UNKNOWN], here's our greeting, Hello World. Now, of course, I want you
to change the greeting and print something else, and I want you to show me what
you did. Here we'll use the Udacity coding environment, and not BlueJay to give
us any of the code that you have developed. Let me show you that. Whenever we
want you to submit programming work, you will see a screen such as the
following. Here we give you a bit of starter code, and some instructions on
what we want you to do. Right now it says, please print Hello Udacity. You can
type your answer in here. Or even better, you can first do the answer in BlueJ
and then just paste it in here. To test your program, scroll down and click the
Test Run button. And here you see the program output. Once you're happy, click
the Submit button. That way we get your work, and get you feedback. In this
case, that it was correct. Now, it's your turn to try it. Sarah will walk you
through your very first programming assignment. Good luck.